hi
there's a gun
this is the quiet car i got to use your
small inside voice in here son there's a
gun hello friends i am naz prez and i am
sitting with the offensively handsome
cast of trains
that would be you we're getting uh it's
offensive guys i'm so excited to talk to
you about this movie it's so good it's
this comedic action thriller it's like
lace with philosophical debates i felt
so exhilarated when i left the theater
and i started thinking about like why it
is that we love action movies and i
thought about how the three of you have
so purposefully and beautifully
contributed to the genre whether it was
through like eternals or fight club or
kick ass
and so while i feel like most of us
could answer why it is we love action
movies i wanted to start off this
conversation by asking the three of you
why do you love making them
love to hear from you brad i think there
was no one we both went straight
oh i actually don't like making them
actually movies
i'm i'm a bit more on the lazy side of
the acting world but this one
specifically you know was
pointing towards more like a jackie chan
who we considered the all-time great are
like buster keaton of our time
and so it was infused with this humor
and um i i guess uh uh like it was just
rife with characters so that's what made
it really fun something i hadn't done
before
made me laugh i think it'll i think
it'll do that for others
i just want to slap white guys around so
like if i need an opportunity to slap
away dude i'm gonna do it he's pretty
good at it and i'm really good at it so
i feel like they like harnessed my
strengths and were like
let's put them in this so we can slap a
bunch of white guys uh i don't know it
was just something i've always wanted to
do man like just white guy
yeah the main white guy
like wouldn't you if someone told you
that you got to sign up to slap wrap hit
around with you wouldn't you take it
exactly right so like so therefore i
wasn't gonna miss this opportunity but
i've always liked like action because
it's like so out of this world it's so
crazy it takes you out of your element
for a little bit and you know you get to
have some fun and laugh with a bunch of
strangers in the theater and you're like
oh wow look that car went through that
plate glass window or i didn't know you
could kill a person with this many ways
with the tray table it's like oh i
didn't know you could punch brian in
there
so many times which if viewers go to see
that you know it's worth the price of
admission he's a method actor so you'll
see real stuff but it was really like
fun to do so and to do it with these two
it was just the caveat it was like just
showing up to a bloody like playground
all day i love that
so true yeah uh why did i sign up for it
i think you know we shot this whole
thing in a pandemic so there was kind of
like a grey cloud around us you know so
going to work every day was just uh was
so much light and joy and you know we
kind of made that our thing to go in and
just make each other like laugh and
break each other on set and um
and then ultimately that's kind of like
what the product that we've made you
know is something that you know is a
good laugh so that was kind of like the
main main draw really yeah well the main
draw for me is the characters because
this movie has the dopest island of
misfit toys
like the author
right the author of the novel that wrote
bullet train
said all of his characters are a bit
strange as if they're floating a few
centimeters above reality and i love
that line because i feel like the three
of you all added stuff to each of your
characters to really bring that to life
on the big screen yeah um so brad one of
the things we love about your
performances is i feel like a recurring
theme is you're either eating or wearing
a hat in them oh my gosh and i read that
ladybugs it's so predictable now it was
your idea so i wanted to know where did
that come from what was giving
paddington what was my idea the ladybugs
bucket hat
oh oh
i didn't want to i didn't want to be in
here for makeup for too long no this was
this way you know
this script came along in like the heart
of lockdown prevex when we're all going
a bit stir crazy and really like
questioning our choices
and this thing came along
and it just made me laugh it just made
me laugh and the other thing about it is
every character had something going on
had their own thing
this wasn't like supporting one idea
everyone like
was was clashing because of their their
their own incentives yeah i knew we'd
get an all-star cast
we kind of did
it all worked out really well man like i
first saw aaron jumped in first and saw
him reading it was i just knew we were
off and running
yeah so where did the bucket had idea
come from though was it paddington
inspired
yes it was paddington it was actually
gilligan my guy's a chump come on he's a
chump so
so they didn't have to reach too far
like exactly and and yeah yeah like
fashion would not be in his but i will
say that it was motivation to want to
fight him because when you see him in
his bucket hat it's like why
[Laughter]
like why is this happening and now
gilligan's island's like theme songs
stuck in my head that's hilarious though
i love that um because he is like this
reticent assassin which is funny brian
you've played the coolest characters you
have such a vast range one second
the book of mormon on broadway to
paperboy in atlanta
but one thing that you've always wanted
to do is a british accent and you got to
do that with lemon so i was wondering
who and what did you listen to to find
lemon's voice you know i didn't really
listen to much well i did listen to the
voice in my head that said if my black
british friends don't like what i'm
doing i'm gonna get my ass
so i heard that over and over again i
was like i can't embarrass them in any
way i want to make sure that i get it
right so you know i had a really great
dialect coach with jameson bryant she's
fantastic i stayed in my accident the
whole time to annoy the hell out of them
i didn't call them fries i called them
chips you know i made sure to like keep
it as authentic as possible uh but yeah
it was fun i mean it was just really fun
you don't really get an opportunity to
to do that as a black american actor to
be able to like step into the british
shoes like so i wanted to you know
explore it and have fun with it right
you took on the toughest accent the
toughest princess
with your dialect coach did you like
listen to any tapes of something
specifically no i really didn't i'm i'm
not that method i was like i wanted to
just like
figure him out in his own because like
lemon is like a foster kid you don't
really know where he's from and i didn't
want to like make him like exactly
placed from one area i wanted him to
kind of be a hodgepodge of a bunch of
things so i just like like leaned in and
just played with a couple of things i
love that yeah aaron uh i was thinking
about what i wanted to ask you when it
came to tangerine and the first thing i
wrote when i left the theater was six
stash
literally like what can i say to him
impossible i don't know if it's top guns
doing but i feel like the tom selleck
stash is back and because i will never
know what it's like to rock one i wanted
to know what was going to limit yourself
i know that's very true
i've tried brian man don't limit
yourself that's true that could be a
thing you could start it thank you
seriously i will what was it like having
it in terms of character and like does
it change your personality or how people
see you when you have stuff like that
i've always wondered i don't even know
how i kind of uh ended up with the stash
i think it was some sort of it was
definitely a choice that uh
i don't know if it was just we were in
lockdown far too long that i got a bit
too experimental with facial hair
or
if it just felt like yeah i think i
think it was kind of like just
discovering this character you know he
wore like his three-piece suit and he
felt like he was kind of like you know
this kind of ultimate flashy kind of
gentleman but really he wasn't you know
and so i think the mustache felt like he
felt like he gave him some kind of class
but really underneath he was
complete trash
[Laughter]
so i don't know but yeah apparently now
it's a it's a thing it's like chris
evans i think he has one in gray man i'm
being told so i think people i think he
i think yeah yeah yeah puts people off
it didn't put me off i'm not totally
answering i was already put off but i
trust him
i trust him yeah well it was remarkable
how it stayed intact with the suit and
everything like through the app it was
real you know yeah i mean it was it
stays on my face
i love it uh but let's talk about the
action in this movie brad i was watching
a conversation you had with adam sandler
a couple years ago and you were saying
how when it comes to stunts most of the
time you like to leave that to the
professionals but the stunt coordinator
on this movie gregor mentor said that
the space on set because you guys are in
a train is so unforgiving that there
wasn't space to hide stunt doubles so a
lot of you guys had to do your own
action so i wanted to know how did the
action help you find your character brad
well first of all our director was david
leach and he was my stunt double we met
on fight club he trained me for the
fights and and we got on so well that we
did several films together after that
and then he went on for greener pastures
so you know he's developed from john
wick to deadpool 2 to us now he he's
developed this
i don't know i keep i keep uh we talked
a lot about jackie chan he's still like
like the hero
and infusing this this comedic element
and so he's got a very specific
signature and that's really what we all
signed on for because it's it's
hilarious
greg and the team they designed these
things in these close quarters that was
that was um
it was just funny it was just funny
there really was nowhere to hide like if
you are sitting on this train that was
made you know to look like a real bullet
train and you are sitting across from
this guy and you have to slam his face
on the table over and over again you
don't have time to go cut and switch
somebody else in there so you want to
kind of stay there and really like make
sure it's as authentic as possible
you're in my personal spaceship i'm
going to always mean
until that restraining order's lifted um
but yeah like you're just going to keep
on you want like david leach makes you
want to do your own stunts you know like
when you see him behind the camera and
you see him jump up and down and you see
him laughing it kind of like
reinvigorates you to like really get in
there and i think most of us signed on
for that i think most of us are like yo
it's david leech we're going to get in
there and really do it and greg were
mentoring that whole stunt team at 87
north they were fantastic like they they
really let us do as much and as little
as we wanted to some did very little but
let us do it you know so it was yeah oh
the fight scenes are so good especially
the one with you brad and bad bunny who
by the way said it was a beautiful
experience working with you and i was
curious what was it like for you to work
with him did he like sing songs together
on set well
he
you know he wanted me to because i'm
really good at it and my spanish is
impeccable but i just said
i said bonnie you know
this is your moment i don't want to rain
on your you know
do you know what i mean but no he jumped
right in he was game he was he was all
in he got the joke and uh we had a
really funny couple of days there brad
said i said bunny yeah he said i said
bunny i get it they're on they're on
your night they're on first day
so amazing how did you guys's fighting
style you know your character's fighting
style match their personalities
i think that was a big i think that was
a big thing for it you know like that's
uh another thing that's really fun in
this movie is that every character's got
their individual style for sure
um my guy's definitely an unpredictable
scrappy little fighter and
i think that's what adds the comedy
element you know what you're saying is
like contain sort of space so you know
you have to use the environment around
you me and brad had this fight in the
food cart and it's literally like you
know was saying that leech would try and
get these chopsticks and like shove him
up his nose or get wasabi and shove it
in his eyes like there's no there's all
these different elements that you could
kind of improvise with and play with and
david leach would kind of like
encourage that kind of kind of uh
behavior and stuff so um that was kind
of great but yeah i mean they got the
best fight sequence in the quiet car i
mean there's always
like yeah this fight is amazing there's
always just a levity that you're trying
to find within it because it's like at
the end of the day there are a bunch of
sociopaths who are trying to
kill each other on the train like
there's no way around it and some fights
are happening in between stops right
like
there's one that's really funny between
brad and i like towards the end where
it's like it's an apology fight so like
here we are trying to defend each other
but at the end of the day he wants an
apology and he's not going to stop until
he gets his apology so it's just all
these different like levels that happen
uh but within you know some can lean a
little bit more slapstick some can be
like all but all the stakes are high
like all the stakes are high so i think
there's that's just um a testimony to
david leech's brain it really isn't it's
so beautiful because you can tell how
the story's moving forward through the
fighting and that was something i really
noticed so many memorable fights though
like you honestly can't pick a favorite
one so many memorable lines too my
favorite line in particular was said by
the elder he says you don't know what
horrible fate you may have missed thanks
to your bad luck and i love this theme
of luck and fate uh because i love
horoscopes no i'm just kidding
what's your sign
[Applause]
so i wanted to ask the three of you guys
are you nary yeah
um
march is the best so i wanted to ask the
three of you guys in your career past
what's something that happened that was
bad luck that actually ended up being
good luck for you
brian oh me first oh come on
uh
bad luck that ended up being good luck
in your career in my career you know
what's really crazy i will say how this
movie came about because like
i remember
david leach calling me and he wanted me
to play this character lemon and i
remember at the beginning at the very
early mechanisms of lemon he wasn't
really like as developed like you know
like especially if he was going to be
opposite like this really cool character
tangerine and what i really
was worried about was like how he would
come off you know i was like well you've
got this central black character that is
on this bullet train that is going
through japan that sticks out like a
sore thumb is he going to be like the
comic dope is he gonna be like the loof
and i didn't want that and so part of me
had a little hesitation was like oh no
david man like i don't wanna follow that
trope i wanna do something different and
the best part about it is that
collaborating with them and
collaborating with david and especially
like brad like really being like i want
you to come in and bring all the things
that you want uh that you see lemon
being made it the best thing that could
have possibly happened on top of the
fact that we were filming this in the
heart of 2020 when like everything
outside of our door was pretty much fire
and brimstone like the social injustice
we were coming up on an election we
didn't know where the world was going to
go and you come on this set with all
these different people from different
places and different backgrounds so
we're like trying to like really like
have a good time so this movie in in
essence was very good luck for me
because it restored my faith to humanity
when i kind of like lost it
um so yeah that was that was bad luck
returning a good look for me what about
you aaron
i swear
i'm trying to think um i mean i saw a
bit of stumbling into um
you know it's like mistake
i don't know no but it's like you know
you never really know
i don't know
you know i think uh
you gotta make a bunch of like mistakes
in order to keep growing i mean so i
don't ever really see anything as bad or
good luck but i do see the sort of
process of like staying on that that
path and that journey of what you want
to follow to i mean i'm always about
manifestation and like
put out there what you know what i'm
after what i want to go for but it
doesn't mean it doesn't come with some
um
disadvantages you know i mean or
mistakes along the way but it's fine
like a friend of mine has this thing on
there
uh sign on there in that on that door it
says
i've made some mistakes in my life i'm
thinking of making some more and i could
sometimes i think of that and then like
you know i'm open just to see where the
path follows you know where it goes i
mean yeah i've always found like the the
missteps inform the next step
but you need that knowledge you need
that wisdom that gained from that to
inform define you know to to refine find
the next step
which you could call success or
um um so i i
i don't bemoan it that much but i do
like i did also appreciate in this
script
one the international cast people coming
from all walks of life clashing
but also this undercurrent of you know
fate versus
a free will and and this kind of
um these kind of themes all in this
undercurrent of this really funny
funny-ass movie yeah fake kind of
brought us all together like in the time
we didn't know we needed each other it
was i would have never imagined that i
make such good friends
like from this thing and so i think you
see that when the movie plays out that
we all like truly care about each other
and you could feel that too just sitting
here crossing you guys brad it's
interesting you mentioned steps because
before i go you're just such a badass
producer and every step that you've
taken has felt so purposeful and
intentional and i think it's such a big
reason why people love seeing whatever
you're in
so because you're such like an amazing
producer i wanted to know as far as
acting goes how many more movies do you
want to do
i don't really know um thank you for the
the
the producing comment or vote of
confidence i've i have two great
partners i have to say who really do a
lot of the heavy lifting and it's really
it's made all the difference in jeremy
kleiner and d.d gardner we've just been
this
really fun garage band since
20 years of who love story and love
artists and
love to like like you know push those
those projects over the hill so that's
been really really fun for me i don't
know i see you know i see slowing down a
little bit i see
of being more specific
uh and choices i do think it's
like a younger person's game in some
sense as far as
you know the real push of the the
industry so i i can't say i still got
some other things i want to do and i
never know until i finish the last one
what you know what the next one's going
to be and we're not going to let him
stop really like he doesn't have a
choice but to continue because
we know that was a nice thing you just
said thank you
it turned into a
threat you guys are amazing thank you so
much for sitting down
i love you guys and talking to me and
putting your art into the world and into
this film i know you guys shot this in
2020 and it's been a long ride and now
it's here so thank you guys so much
congratulations thank you guys so much
for watching